my name is Peter Santaniello it's this
is beneath cave where we journey
together in a key of Ukraine through the
eyes of the locals five episodes five
completely different stories one amazing
city
[Music]
[Applause]
hello Peter oh yeah I'm good how are you
good I'm not gonna act like I don't know
you because without me talking anymore
where are you taking us I'm taking you
to this Bridge bridge so that's where we
are
[Music]
let it be the beginning I'm half Syrian
half Ukrainian I was born in Ukraine in
makeevka it's a small town next to the
nyet
then when I was three we moved to Syria
my father was in the military and we
lived there a couple of years and then
moved to other cities I ended up in
Damascus and that's my favorite city of
all in theory I mean I had a great job I
had a lot of friends and I was happy and
then the war started obviously yes
everybody believed that it is quite
temporary and it will end soon like it's
just a matter of few months but I
remember when when we were in the taxi
and
me my brother sitting in the back and my
father was in front and I remember
hearing him crying and so that was the
moment I knew that that might not just
last for two weeks you look at a map of
the planet of Earth and you see done yes
I don't know if there's in the history
of humanity one person that's gone from
one civil war immediately to the next
one I'm attracted I'm attractive actions
I do love you just because
when I am in a bridge I feel that I am
present and I feel that I am kind of
relaxed there is the and then there is a
new beginning and you're in the middle
and you are moving and there is a
connection and there is a way I don't
know maybe that's too much of a
philosophy I guess but that's just the
feeling that I get every every single
time I get on a bridge I feel so present
so in the moment we were planning to
spend two weeks in vignettes to see mom
to see grandmother you know that was the
plan
could you feel because of your
experience like these changes happening
like this is energy bubbling up or
whatever it might not feeling might be I
have no actually it started
I started from watching the news and
hearing what is being reported because
that was exactly the same scenario that
happened and then here in the master you
know the way the news
and the way things were presented and
again you know people in in that area
were as helpful as people in the
and they they used to say and repeat the
exact same phrases saying that all this
is temporary this will and in amongst
this will add in a month and a half well
the day we had there are tickets to Kiev
that was the day when they train station
and then has got bombed and it was on
fire and I was reading that on the news
and I knew that we have a train to take
from there
remember your initial feelings of
leaving done yes he weren't as much
attached as Damascus or working and I
remember the moment when I left Damascus
it was exactly the moment when I started
falling in love with the city and I was
saying to myself I am so lucky that I
live in such a beautiful city and it
happened again in the music when I said
to myself Oh finally I loved and yet so
much and this is the city where I want
to be the next thing you know is that
you're on a train with just few things
that you had time to pack moving to Kiev
[Music]
you consider yourself a refugee or not
do you ever think about this you know
that's an interesting question because
it depends on what's your definition of
the word refugee well in terms of for
like if I if we take a look at what
happens so yeah I I lived in the country
and then I have to leave that country
because of war and because that was my
desire I guess yeah that makes me
somehow a refugee but I don't want to
belittle the suffering and the hardship
that some refugees like those Syrians
have fled Syria and went to Germany or
for example those who have lost a member
of their family due to the war or have
suffered some those are scary things due
to the situation so in just a short
period of time you went from Damascus
Don yet now you're in Kiev
what was that first feeling when you're
like okay I'm gonna make my home here I
had this feeling a long time ago and
that was the first time I visited Kiev
and I remember coming out of the
underground on Maidan and the
underground you know that wasn't sin on
Maidan it's very complex and it's dark
and has a lot of people a lot of beggars
and then you come out and there's this
whole scene that is opening up for you
of beauty and fountains and people and
buildings and sunshine and that it was
the moment that I felt that I can die
just to live here yeah because I thought
that that is my city
I was made here
this is one of my favorite places here
it has been many years ago when I first
came here and for a visit I remember
when I had this luckam Kiev from up
there and it felt so it felt so
liberating because you can see
everything away because of the beauty
that you can see
[Music]
if we took about stability of course no
I don't feel stability here but I feel
that I am in my right place in the right
time and that's what makes me feel safe
okay so get this I heard these these
doors that slide over I heard our
supposedly reinforced doors for if
there's a nuclear winter nuclear
holocaust and the population can go and
stay in these metros this is what I was
told in all Soviet cities Stalin
bilities yeah so this big door closes
okay I don't know if Yugi rumor or true
but what would it be for it could be
that or for floods right I allow myself
to fall in love with the city I am in
and so far that's the city where I feel
at home here yes more so than Damascus
wonderful yes more so than any other
city mmm
why I am looking for this thank you for
the monuments of motherland way over
there yes because that monument somehow
tells you about the spirits of Kiev the
spirit of this feminine spirit but
strong that had to build herself from
ashes and this is the kind of a city
that helps you to do that to build
yourself again from ashes to arise from
ashes and that's how somehow I feel so
intimate and so close to it and I feel
that we are you know yeah I feel that
this city is like a grandmother
mm-hmm sir Ileana you move - he
you didn't have a job lined up how did
you start this language school so we
have some cookies please feel free yet
to mix this a rigid topic of grammar
with some sweets and some fun
and I guarantee the fun well and the
school guarantees the cookie I was
working as an English teacher in a
school and then something's happened and
we were like as a team we're not sure if
that school is going to is going to
continue you know working or not
I was just sitting at home and thinking
that okay this I need to go over and
over and then I thought why not to think
outside of the box like if I just if I
just move one step forward what would I
do if I had like all the chances what
would I do and then I said to myself I
would open my own school so do you think
if if you didn't have to leave Damascus
in onions do you think you would have
had the courage to start a business
never sure about that never because for
me at least you only get the courage to
do something new and you don't have
anything to lose anymore and then you
say okay so what is there to lose and
you feel free to to risk it that's cool
yes and that's the thing I've always
wanted to try the zipline yes here
specially here what let's do it let's do
it seriously not a bridge too long
of course yay let's do that
I once read this thing that you cannot
label things as good or bad so I guess
that's part of the experience when
things get tough
they are weenies of that's what they are
do you suffer a lot but then you
understand that that just gave you
another opportunity to open something up
inside you or to move a step forward or
to try something new
and that's a blessing in itself do you
understand that that was the best thing
that ever happened to you
but of course you would never wish that
to happen again
[Applause]
[Music]